[Music]
the nominations in the drama series
category are the 70th annual Emmy
nominations were announced Thursday as
always there were surprises and snuck so
silly
this is a scored eight noms but three
cast favorites were snubbed Chrissie
Mets who scored a nom for season one and
Justin Hartley and Mandy Moore who are
both thought to be major contenders this
year III missed and flustered and it's
not kind of you just admit that you love
Randall more we can stop pretending to
know but Sandra Oh made history for her
work on killing Eve she's the first
Asian woman to earn a nomination in the
lead actress in a Drama category
the good doctor standout Freddie
Highmore failed to score nomination
lieutenant Cole welcome aboard
overall Netflix for the most nominations
112 to be exact
including a surprise outstanding actor
in a limited series Nam for Jesse
Plemons his episode of Black Mirror USS
Callister scored seven total mom's other
fun surprises include Issa Rae for her
work on HBO's insecure Ted Danson's
outstanding comedy acronym for the good
place in a statement he said in part
quote it's truly an honor to be
nominated and especially nice not to be
the oldest person in the category and
Edie Falco who snagged an outstanding
actress in a limited series nomination
for the Menendez murders based on what
happened that week
is it possible Eric and his brother
honestly believed their parents were
going to kill them but get this past
any favorites modern family and orange
is the new black were shut out
completely the 70th annual Emmy Awards
air Monday September 17th on NBC
[Music]